tickets need to be treated as goods that
at the very least if i buy a ticket i
should be able to give it to you if I
want to and then I are mandated but yeah
well yes exactly hi I'm Matt Welch for
recent TV at Freedom Fest in Las Vegas
with an old friend of reason Andrew
Langer Andrew heads up the Institute for
liberty yeah I FL is an advocacy
organization based in DC we focus on
American exceptionalism crony capitalism
property rights and right now doing a
lot of pushing back against what we see
is the rise of tyranny in America crony
capitalism what do you pointing out well
one of the issues we're working on right
now in our favorite issues is think fan
freedom it's the idea that folks have
property rights inherent in tickets to
concerts and sporting events that they
buy and the fact is that you have a lot
of big actors in the marketplace who
have used the power of regulation to
feather their own beds and are in fact
trying to restrict your ability to give
your tickets to someone else or to sell
them at either a profit or loss on a
secondary market place like StubHub or
craigslist or what have you now some of
the teams are like look blocking out
stubhub is that what's happening here
they're trying to create their own
secondary market place and insisting
that you go through them how you use
them and trying to enforce it by well by
creating what are called restrictive
tickets which is where you have to show
up at the venue with your credit card
and photo ID so if you can't say if you
can't go to a game or you can't go to a
concert you are frankly Sol is that
legal I mean can they create a contract
well you know what it is is that over
the last hundred years or so tickets
have been considered contracts as
opposed to goods in the marketplace
contracts of adhesion as you know as we
all know contracts generally are except
to do actually be negotiated by both
parties but we think that it's a legal
fiction that you know who's the reasons
for it decades ago don't hold now the
tickets are very hard to counterfeit
today that's one of the reasons why they
had them there were also there was also
a racial component where venue owners
and operators wanted the the right to
kick people out if they weren't the
right color or ethnicity so it was you
know it's one of those things where
these legal fictions were created
whereas now there's really known
you for either those we certainly don't
want folks to be able to kicked out
because of the color of their skin or
their country of origin and frankly the
anti-counterfeiting measures are they
work very well so we think that good
that tickets need to be treated as goods
that at the very least if I buy ticket I
should be able to give it to you if I
want to and then I are mandated whatever
yeah well yes exactly or and more than
more to the point if so I want to sell
it I should be able to choose the venue
on which I want to sell to what's
happened it used to be very shady
practice right you used to go down to a
venue as a guy in a corner in an alley
now we had this very vibrant marketplace
that technology has been able to match
willing buyers with willing sellers we
now have a real reflection of market
value in tickets and I'm frankly the the
big ticket agencies they don't like that
they don't like they don't want to have
to adapt so what they do is they want to
use the power of government to destroy
their competition that's fundamentally
wrong how is government getting involved
right now and what are you doing to to
beat back well one of the ways you know
it was a big flap in Tennessee
ticketmaster went into Tennessee I they
wanted to have legislation out there
that would enshrine their right to
engage in this restrictive ticketing and
sort of enshrine their ability to
control their own secondary market
places we went in there and said no no
this is wrong this is crony capitalism
at it's worse the problem is that if
there were real competition and venues
if ticketmaster didn't control eighty
percent of market share then it wouldn't
be such a you know then we wouldn't have
such a problem there would be there
would be different modes that were
coming out there but what happens
ticketmaster not only do they control
the ticketing they own live nation so
they manage venues they manage artists
there it's all sort of up and down the
food chain there and it squeezes out the
ability of anybody else to get in there
and have true competition so the only
way you have real competition is through
secondary market places like StubHub and
craigslist so we want to make sure that
those entities have the opportunity to
develop fully if angel isn't anybody
knows if you go to a venue that is
managed by ticketmaster it is a very
difficult clergy process to buy tickets
you go to stubhub you've got a great
model for doing business you can pick
your seats you can pick this you can
pick that you'd see where you're sitting
you can get a view sometimes of where
you're sitting you know rather than
adapt to that they want it you took a
master wants to destroy it awesome free
the tickets it's about
time Andrew lenka thank you for doing
the Lord's work for recent TV I am Matt
Welch